hey guys how's it going so today we're
going to be making cupcakes that look
like my dog now someone tweeted me this
so thank you so much because after I saw
this I immediately ran to the Internet
and ordered all of the supplies that I
needed and here they are we're gonna
make white cupcakes with white icing
we're gonna preheat of 350 blend cake oh
god you'd think I'd know how to do this
by now those of you that don't know my
god looks like this is Maddie hey Mia D
say hi you're cute
okay bye bye I'll see you later I gotta
wash my hands I'm also going to be
making icing and you go 1 cup of water
and you go little treat your a little
treat look at this measuring it's like I
don't want to mess this up because I
want to eat it we're gonna mix you up
just I don't really want to clean the
blender be honest with you this is good
everything's good everything's great
everything's awesome I'm having a good
time
[__] workout for the day
now our cupcake tins are nicely placed
into our tray I'm gonna put in some of
the batter
all right eggs all ready to go into the
oven wow that's hot that's hot
my face is burning set my alarm for 18
minutes okay it's time to make the icing
we've need three cups of powdered sugar
1/3 cup butter margarine softened - oh
God
should i mix should i make a double
recipe do you think let's see let's see
how many three cups is one - do you
think this will be enough icing for a
dozen cupcakes
okay Matt says that says no so okay okay
all right now I need to figure out how
much butter I need it's a little bit of
paper on our butter not a good taste
pure vanilla let's do a little drip
that's probably one that's probably -
that's probably a half so you need to
gradually mix it in I use my mixer maybe
we just do this with a little bit of the
butter I should probably use the mixer
you guys haven't seen this mixer in like
a lifetime oh god is it happy how do I
even unlock okay my goodness this is
gonna be quite quite the disaster can
you help
wait okay never mind I don't need help
it looks like I did it all by myself I'm
not worthy not worthy I'm not worthy use
this I don't even know what I would use
for this I'm sure that's the thing
that's going on with the car
good I did it let's continue on with
this icing and hope for the best I
probably waited too long at this point
whoa whoa whoa this is great if I got to
do anything
stress speed it up a little maybe speed
it up a little more jeez holy crap holy
crap
slow down you seem to be struggling
maybe we'll give you a little more milk
it's real thick icing I don't know if
this is gonna achieve what I'm going for
tell me how this homemade ice I sing is
no but I want Matt to have a taste to
not take a look rather head frosting
from the can
my name's Mia thank you so much for
being a really great mixer okay you
clean this up and then we'll start our
decorating
oh wow some icing is already coming out
okay that's good that's a good sign it's
a good sign so we need to make it look
like Maddie
there we go here's like those little
nose and then probably should have made
this thicker huh it doesn't look like
Maddie
the icing I think is too warm it's
failing it so okay we've done this let's
just stop
let's just put some more icing up on top
of this um and see what happens
man this is not working out so well
let's put on Matty's face cuz I'm so
upset
okay well uh I guess I'll make a few
more with maybe just a little bit of
icing did not work out the way that I
was hoping I'm very upset maybe I needed
not buttercream frosting maybe that was
my problem maybe it's just not cut out
for life baking for me god I even got
professional decorating stuff today's
the day I think the cream icing might
have been the problem all right we'll
just put on some little Maddy eyes to
make it still look like Maddy
there we go yeah looks good so I'd like
just a cheese pizza please
with garlic knots the golden garlic
knots if you if you will all right so
whoever things clearly didn't work out
the way that I had anticipated so this
is oh here left foot for the time being
I've got some icing in the freezer so
I'm gonna give it another shot hopefully
try to compete with this mess feels a
little chill let's try this again shall
we oh crap now it's actually frozen and
I can't get it out shoot I just need to
make nice cupcakes that look like my dog
for my friends and it's not happening
I'm a little bit distraught right now do
you want to come and see what happened
yeah we're out a mole does this look
like the picture the Maddie cupcakes
wait so so you see the picture that I
send you the bees food on the cupcake
well it's supposed to look like this
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait what
did you do wait you got to add hair it's
like you may I try but if this is what
happened when I tried to add more I
figure you know the problem that's good
yeah that's really good kind of to go
fight you know like that's a lot of
sugar don't look when I do it it just
smell this yeah dude of 8-1 you got to
really push it
whoa make his little ears oh it's gonna
be perfect
you think oh wow look at this I haven't
just use that icing to begin with coffee
icing really God is this disgusting that
tastes like get that out of here okay
creamy coffee creamy gropes pig thanks
for watching guys I hope you leave me
some comments and let me know everything
that I did wrong as per usual I actually
tried it though that is good
that tastes good no ideas little sweet
it is a little sleep I'll see you guys
later I think I just inhaled
let me know the comments also what you
guys like me to make next see you later
so I'm gonna be disaster
no we candle